[Music]
can you imagine never worrying about
money again
would that be like what kind of a
condition would your life have to be in
to never worry about money again you
know what's interesting is it's not an
amount of money that causes that the
Bible says godliness with contentment is
great gain how would you be content well
if your money was completely out of
control you're deeply in debt and you
were content that would make you
psychotic stupid you shouldn't be
content if everything is torn up but
godliness with contentment is great gain
and so what it amounts to is not that
everything is perfect but it's that we
have a plan and we are working towards a
series of wise decisions through a
series of wise decisions to get control
of our money so contentment is a journey
financial success is a journey it's not
an amount now we talked a lot about
millionaires around here millionaire
status but I mean truthfully me know
there's not a lot of money anymore I
mean it'll create you know 80 thousand
bucks of your income or something if you
made 8% on it right but that's just you
know that's not like rich anymore it's a
whole lot more than most people got okay
but I mean you really want to aim higher
than that even so if you're making if
you have a game plan and your game like
a budget and you know that this month
you're going to get to eat this month
the lights are paid this month we're
moving towards through our baby steps
getting rid of debt or we're building
our emergency fund or we're investing
for our kids college in our retirement
towards paying off a house or this month
whatever as long as you can see that
you're moving in the right direction and
this month is taken care of there's a
sense of power there empowerment using
an 80s term in powered you empower
people there's an 80s term right
but you're empowered and that that's you
should be content in the middle of that
that contentment does not mean apathy
and contentment does not mean lazy
contentment is not a hound dog laying in
the Sun on the front porch he is content
but he's also lazy I'm very content but
I worked my butt off it has nothing to
do with activity level it has nothing to
do with ambition contentment is a
spiritual condition and when it comes to
your finances being content never
worrying about money again is not an
amount of money you'll never get enough
money to not worry about it
again or you could get 10 billion
dollars and you'd still be wringing your
hands and worried if you were out of
control if you didn't have a plan if you
didn't have a series of wise principles
that you use for making your decisions
with that's why you don't hear me use
the phrase financial independence a lot
of people in the financial world use
that you can become financially
independent I'm not really mad about it
or anything but I just don't think you
ever do what are you independent of
people you're always gonna have to
interact with people I mean you can
still get sued for something you did
maybe you didn't even do you're not
independent ever there's never enough
money to where you just absolutely are
above the rules you're above common
sense you're above the use of wisdom and
now a financial independence means you
can pay your bills if that's what it
means to you then okay if financial
independence means you can retire with
dignity then okay we can aim at that but
the phrase itself is a little bit strong
for me independence not really trying to
be independent I want to be dependent on
my spouse I want to be looking at my
grandbabies
I am working to change your life and
your children and your grandchildren
life I'm not independent I'm not that
that kind of sounds selfish when you say
it the financial independence it sounds
selfish maybe it's not and maybe I know
that's not what everybody means when
they say it so I'm not picking on you if
you use that phrase but financial
independence is not my goal it's not my
goal and so I will never stop earning
money and growing wealth how much is
enough at some point shouldn't you just
stop no no the more I've got the more I
can give I have a gift I'm an ability to
earn money beyond my wildest dreams so
why would I stop besides that I didn't
earn the money hurting someone every
time I earn a dollar it's helped
somebody sell a couple million books and
make a buck apiece that's a couple
million dollars right and a couple
million people got helped with the
information in that book so I think it's
probably all working out for everybody
except for some of you that are left
wing nut jobs but I mean you can't
figure this out anyway so we're not
talking to you but the point is you
never worry about money again sometimes
we think that that's an amount when I
was young I used to think if I just had
a million dollars it was an amount if I
get this amount I'll never have to worry
about money again
if I hit a million dollars I'm a net
worth I don't mean those cash by you
know worry less yeah yeah if you got a
billion dollars you'd worry less than if
you had two dollars I got that because
you don't to worry about food you don't
worry about you know a place to live you
know the basics of life right so it is
less but you never really become
independent nor should you really want
to I think I'm very dependent on God the
provider of this that he gave me to
manage but what would it be like to be
on such a plan and have the wise
wisdom principles in place by which you
operated your finances that allowed you
to not worry anymore
not only where this month's a necessity
is taken care of but we're starting to
look into the future enjoy the today and
have a future that is bright well that
requires a plan Financial Peace
University is that plan it's the only
place that we have where we put
everything together and almost 5 million
people have been through it to show you
the wisdom principles and go this is
what happens if you're wise these are
the steps you do this is what you do
this is how you get at it and you can do
that you can do it so it's it's a
one-year membership all the videos are
online the audios are online everything
you can get a hold of for a whole year
you can get every dollar plus tied to
your bank account for a year so you've
got everything lined up that way and you
can go to the night and week class any
time during that year you want to and
we're going to give you the kit to go to
the class with as well people going
through the class or paying on fifty
three hundred dollars worth of debt
saving twenty seven hundred dollars in
the first 90 days it's an $8,000
turnaround we'll show you the wisdom
principle so you don't worry anymore now
you're not gonna be rich at the end of
nine weeks are they into one year most
of you aren't but you're starting a
journey a permanent decision to not
operate my life by stupid principles
anymore and instead operate them by
wisdom principles and you can do that
any area of your life you can decide I'm
you know our parenting we don't know
what we're doing we're raising a couple
of wolfs here I mean I got a chance
change how we're parenting this and you
can get with somebody get information
get wisdom principles like Meg Meeker
was on here yesterday with me and you
can learn wisdom principles on parenting
and you don't just apply them for one
month
you ply them as long as you're alive
there's wisdom principles we'll take you
through the different ages when your
children are grown and have grandkids
you're still still pop a day if I'm
still with all of them another night I'm
still Papa Dave wisdom principles apply
these scriptural principles give you
guidelines to operate your life and you
want to worry anymore because you've got
a process you're engaging in it's
powerful you guys it's a powerful
thought you're not independent you
plugged in this is the Dave Ramsey show